welcome back our boss conan o'brien
i don't really think of myself as your
boss really no i don't
i don't know i think of myself as sort
of like a
emperor an all-seeing all-knowing
omniscient
emperor who sits on a high throne more
like a god king
yeah sure he gladly accepts the title
[Music]
please welcome our god king
conan o'brien to the podcast being our
boss
or god king you know we want to make
sure that uh sonia and i are doing our
part
to make you cool i didn't know that's
what the objective was but okay
i think what sona is really saying is i
didn't think that was possible well with
all of us combined i think we can we can
make something happen
we'll try i have a question for sonia
you've
seen some of my clueless gamers are you
legitimately stunned
at my lack of ability and knowledge
in the gaming world i am impressed
you've definitely involved yourself
in the gaming space i feel like you're i
feel like you're doing okay you're on
the right track all right well
again you're a very supportive person i
appreciate that
uh so that is the encouragement i need
that's exactly and that's the
encouragement i
don't get from sona obsession
yep yeah who's always putting me down
and saying you're an idiot
maybe if you behaved a little more like
sonia i would be more motivated so just
think about that
let's get started all right so there was
a a big news item
sorry last word last word sona okay okay
yeah last word com keep you humble okay
go for it but all right be good okay so
there was a there was
okay okay humble be like sonia there was
big
be like sonia to the tenth power over
now let's go
go ahead blab quickly we're moving on um
sonia and i are very excited about this
because
one of the best games of all time the
last of us
it is about the story of joel who's kind
of a smuggler in a post-apocalyptic
world
[Music]
he's uh oh is it always post-apocalyptic
why is no one ever living in the year is
1998 things are pretty good there are
some problems
but the economy is humming along and
society moves forward
no one ever does a video game set in
that reality
it has to be a post-apocalyptic
landscape where the rules are
there are no rules and everyone's
fighting for survival is that correct
i feel like pre-apocalyptic just doesn't
have the same ring it doesn't have the
same ring to it
well okay i know but shouldn't someone
at least
try it a video game about going to the
grocery store
well maybe that's just animal crossing
yeah i don't know i wish someone would
create a game where everything's okay on
earth
and occasionally someone's like oh yeah
my salt levels are a little high
my doctor says a little less salt in the
diet
little less cured meats and keep my
water intake up
and that's about it some high stakes
anyway continue so
the last of us takes place in a
post-apocalypse where there are zombies
of course there were zombies i think
there's a law that congress passed like
eight years ago
that you have to have zombies or you're
not allowed to operate in the gaming or
entertainment sphere
that's like a law that was passed
because when are there not
zombies seriously their zombies are now
showing up in movies
i saw a production of on the waterfront
recently
and it was with zombies they're doing
you know what i mean death of a salesman
willie lowman is a zombie
it's everywhere if we hadn't passed that
bill what would you
what could we have instead uh
yetis yetis yeah
yetis you know the abominable snowman a
bigfoot something
just does it always have to be a zombie
and guess what they eat
brains when you have zombies over for
dinner you never you know
you have them over when you have them
over for dinner you better have [ __ ]
brains
a big a lot of brains in a bowl no one's
ever like should we go mexican
no they're brains we gotta have br it's
the zom
right right it's just wouldn't they want
to try
mexican you just you send them an
invitation for dinner
to your house okay and they come and
they come smashing through the door even
though i left it open
and then i'm like hey guys tonight i
thought we'd mix it up i tried tapas
no no seriously i know we we have brains
we're thawing them but just let's have
tom
[Music]
oh yeah yeah yeah no it's it's like
small portions yeah bite size it's nice
isn't it
do you want the brains i'm good
and he's becoming elmo
people put zombies in games because it's
exciting
like it's exciting to fight zombies how
would you do against fighting zombies
oh i have it all figured out i've talked
about this a lot with andy richter
oh oh yeah we both have different plans
andy uh
has a really good idea which is first of
all i don't know why
in all these shows they hang out in hot
humid climates to fight zombies
right everyone knows the first thing you
have to do is go to a very cold climate
where zombies freeze right my plan was
get to denver
airport the airport in denver okay
because what you want is a big flat
space
because one of the last place you want
to be is in a forest where a zombie can
just come out from behind a tree
and i don't know why the people in
walking dead decided
let's just hang in georgia forever no
leave you've got a car in six days
you can be at the denver airport then
you can see
for a hundred miles in any direction and
what you can do
is lure the zombies onto those walking
sidewalks you know those sidewalks that
move
and lure them onto those so if even if
one gets through you learn onto that and
it's on that thing forever walking the
wrong way
and meanwhile you have plenty of food
and the zombies there for all eternity
walking in the wrong direction and
you're in in denver which is not the
worst place to be
i love how in depth you've thought this
out it's all i think about
sonia very detailed and honestly not
wrong you're sitting there munching one
of those great giant pretzels
and the zombies walking on the thing and
going the wrong way
no harm to anybody and he's getting an
aerobic workout
and you're you're you're good
everything's good do you think that
you're just making him stronger
if he's just endlessly on the treadmill
that's a great he's getting his cardio
in yeah but they can't build muscle mass
because they're dead so what's happening
is eventually his legs are just going to
wear out
and fall off oh and then he's going to
be a torso that's just rolling
on that moving sidewalk in denver
and you're like hey what's going on
yeah yeah whatever hey look i'm headed
down to starbucks do you want something
flat white you want a flat white i'll
get you one
sona what's your strategy do you have a
zombie strategy have you also thought
about this oh
just i'll just die i i really don't
think i'll fight
at all i think i'll just give in
accept my fate like ridiculous no first
of all
i think your greatest weapon is your
voice
you're very loud huh and abrasive
huh i think the zombies would quickly
leave just from me talking yeah you'd be
like hey
what are you doing here oh i had an idea
wait you want to be
oh hold on a second i'm getting a text
and it'd be like let's go
i'm so shrill they'll just leave so
between the two of you
who do you think is going to last the
longest me even even when i'm not
trying yeah sona's going to last longer
because she is a survivor
she is she's a survivor i'm not even
joking there i think sona
survives anything that comes our way
sona and attack survive
and uh i'm a redhead i'm an odd
you know sort of genetic outlier yeah no
one who sees me
in person thinks i'm going the distance
so
if it happens during the summer and the
zombies don't get you
this your sunburn will just end you
probably
like it's true any skin condition will
get you before a zombie apocalypse does
it'll be heat stroke before anything yes
it'll be a heat stroke and
you know like a melanoma in some place
where no one ever gets a melanoma it was
undiscovered he has a melanoma on his
bicuspid
on his tooth that stone doesn't even
seem possible but it's spreading rapidly
yeah i don't know did you ever smile in
the sun one time
i smile in the sun conan do you think
you would play the last of us
i'm gonna say that i will play the game
great there we go